ladies and gentlemen please welcome the
newlyweds mr and mrs simon doyle
you must meet archul puero my
congratulations madam mercy
but he's only the greatest detective
alive
i suspect you invited me for reasons
other than the fun
you had something so high we have the
karnak all to ourselves a chef and
enough champagne to fill the nile
when you have money no one is ever
really your friend
it's too late to change events it's time
to face the consequence
someone is dead
[Music]
the crime
is murder
ever again
is what the murderer
is one of you were you aware of any
grudges madam is used to getting what
she wants
[Music]
never again
i don't feel safe here
i don't feel safe with any of them
there are so many conflicting hates and
jealousies
oh i like this did you see or hear
anything
i did not trust her i still don't what
did you do last night you accused me of
murder
he accuses everyone of murder it is a
problem i admit
that murder was methodically bland
[Music]
can i not trust you what do you want me
to say
[Music]
[Applause]
someone else is dead
you lie in my face lock the doors
the murderer is here and we'll stay here
[Music]
[Music]
you